find bre mind you i'm not complaining in
i have a few more hing for but in case
you for here the president in
janu
order
det
naal uned
states
sends
a what is he sending to the terror world
let
expert jih watch who here with us today
sir thanks for joining us you on one
hand glad get open but on the other hand
we
must
what
cling guantanamo was all about human was
all about acting the terrorist n alq
narrative gu if it some horrible torture
pal was anything but and now  to turn
back is only to give them more amm they
us
fair enough but but here let's talk a
little bit about erer today talking
about i think he was pointing the finger
at congress saying the reason why it's
taken this long and maybe the reason why
it's even staying open we're just gna
look the other way and keep it open what
do you have to say about that well i
think he's forced by necessity to it
open
rep
that we
ofir is a
detained
training alq
trad
re
keep
c think he moving
cent he  announced for re and it is
designed to show that he tough on terror
but you know the perfume is out of the
ble cat is out of the bag most of the
most lethal people who are at guantanamo
have already been released and they're
already waging war against the united
states back again in their home
countries think probably what his trial
will turn into will be a propaganda
circus in which he will air all his
grian against the united states and be
given an international platform to do so
and it's really  unc because he
essentially pl guilty a couple of years
ago in an extensive document that he
wrote to the prosecutor explaining why
he did what he did with multiple
references to the quran and islamic
teaching explaining why he was waging
jih against the uned states that should
have been enough put end whole aff with him
right mr sp before let you go we are
happy that staying open will be military
trials versus civilian trials say new
york city yes can't
helped
fair
time